so it's still very very early and we
want to be really careful not to
overstate the promise or the potential
of any one treatment for coronavirus but
I did want to update you about
chloroquine we have news that the FDA
has approved on an emergency use basis
the use of chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine from the strategic
national stockpile to look at using it
to treat corona virus in some patients
now I want to be really clear here
because there's so many people
misunderstanding this because Donald
Trump has been over selling it there are
many possible treatments being looked at
okay we've got chloroquine with and
without as if throw Meissen we've got
rammed as severe we have a combination
of two different HIV drugs with and
without azithromycin we've got some
antibody treatments convalescent plasma
or plasma as Donald Trump referred to it
a few days ago dozens of other
possibilities drugs and development
there's dozens and dozens of things
going on Trump has been over selling
chloroquine with as if throw Meissen for
a couple of weeks now dr. Anthony Fauci
has been careful not to oversell it it
is not a proven treatment the letter
that we now have seen from the FDA which
does approve this for some emergency use
is also very cautious to say that this
is not a drug approved for treating
coronavirus the FDA goes on to say based
upon limited in vitro and anecdotal
clinical data in case series chloroquine
and chloroquine hydroxychloroquine
sulfate are currently recommended for
treatment of hospitalized coronavirus
patients in several countries and a
number of national guidelines report
incorporating recommendations regarding
use of it in the setting of kovat 19 the
fda encourages the conduct and
participation in randomized controlled
clinical trials that may produce
evidence concerning the effectiveness in
treating corona virus the FDA is issuing
an emergency use emergency use don't
remember what a stands for but the idea
of allowing emergency use to facilitate
the availability of chloroquine during
the pandemic
to treat patients for whom a clinical
trial is not available or participation
is not feasible so making clear that
we're not approving the drug for
chloroquine we're approving the drug for
discretionary emergency use when the
patient can't participate in a clinical
trial it goes on to say having concluded
that the criteria for issuance of this
authorization is met I am authorizing
the emergency use as described in the
scope of authorization for treatment of
coronavirus when clinical trials are not
available or participation is not
feasible so we are waiting on results
from what are called randomized clinical
randomized controlled trials what we
have so far as a number of small trials
have shown is conflicting information we
have some small sample sizes that say
the chloroquine treatment has worked
well we have other small samples that
say you know the people who didn't get
it did just as well as the people who
did and as Anthony Fauci has pointed out
you have to be comparing the new
treatment to some standard of care and
you need to be randomizing it just
because we've found some small studies
with a Korell correlation does not mean
that we have found a causal link and
case in point when you see just as many
studies that say the control group did
just as well you have to question the
value of this as a therapeutic treatment
we need a large properly done randomized
controlled trial until we get that we
won't really know so the FDA I believe
is doing the right thing here it seems
that the side effects and the risks are
reasonable assuming that you're getting
an EKG of patients that you're going to
give this treatment to chloroquine can
effect what's called the QT QTc interval
it's a heart related thing the FDA says
in limited situations it can be tried
when you can't get access to a clinical
trial doing the EKG is a very important
thing it's a constant balance of risk
reward side effects and the impact of
not trying it when things start to get
very very dire meanwhile there are also
people who are
taking chloroquine for the actual
approved uses who are now having trouble
getting it because many countries are
starting to stockpile chloroquine that's
another issue which we'll talk about at
another time but everything has a cost
is the point let's take a quick break
much more coming up right after this